If we're talking about paying for 75 gallons of solution, we need to think about
three points of intersection made by each of the three company lines, and our
very familiar now vertical x equals 75 line. If we're curious about the least
amount Grant could pay, we need to see which one of these three points of
intersection has the lowest y value, or the smallest y coordinate. Of these
three points of intersection, this one is the lowest, so it must be the one that
we're interested in. The Y value of this point, if we follow this grid line
over, looks to be 500, 600, 700, 800. So the best deal that Grant could get if
he wants to buy 75 gallons of solution will be paying $800. This point that
we're talking about is a point of intersection between the purple line and the
orange line, and the orange line corresponds to company 2. So company 2 is the
one that's going to give him the $800 deal on 75 gallons of solution.